le musée de la ville séparée en deux
univers parallèles de monde relié par un
thème le vintage super mario des
vaisseaux spatiaux et des voitures de
course peuplent cet espace retrogaming
joueurs initiés et débutants se côtoient
c'est un peu dur hein parce que moi j'ai
pas l'habitude de joie c'est un jeu de
voiture j'aime bien laver la vitesse
mais là j'ai pas trop l'habitude donc
j'essaye mais bon c'est rigolo c'est
rigolo c'est mon fils qui joue
d'habitude et mon mari elle avait pas de
jeu vidéo quand tu étais petit jeu mais
elle avait des bonnes notes à l'école
vous appuyez sur les touches jouées ce
que ça donne
à droite
nintendo sega et sony des consoles en
libre accès jusqu'au tournoi multi
joueurs sur le jeu bomberman d'une
chronologie bouleversée entre années 70
et 90 pour faire découvrir aux enfants
les anciennes consoles de notre époque
quoi donc voilà un peu de nostalgie
l'idée c'est vraiment que ce soit
intergénérationnel c'est que ça touche
un public qui soit un public de jeunes
adultes mais c'est aussi de mélanger
vraiment les générations les plus jeunes
les trentenaires les quarantenaires qui
ont connu ces jeux et qui en jouait
enfant mais aussi les personnes plus
âgées qui n'ont pas forcément connus ces
jeux mais qu'il est re découvre autre
ambiance mais toujours rétro avec
l'exposition temporaire du musée veste
en cuir tourne-disque flipper les
visiteurs redécouvre des objets du
siècle dernier
cette treizième nuit européenne des
musées est rassemblé près de 400
personnes à la croisée des deux mondes
du musée de la ville